merci la parole est à Monsieur sido
merci chers collègues
il se trouve que je suis un je fais
parmi des anciens dans cette honorable
assemblée et très honnêtement c'est bien
la première fois en plus de 20 ans que
je vois un débat de cette qualité
[Applaudissements]
alors je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte que nous sommes en train à cette
heure-ci de donner de la même impression
que le peuple français retient de
l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
ainsi à ceux-ci près
non attendez attendez à ceci près j'ai
entendu un journaliste tout à l'heure
dans la salle des conférences faire ces
observations et nous dire que finalement
ici au Sénat c'était l'obstruction
cordiale
je trouve que le mot était bien choisi
mais est-ce que vous rendez compte quand
même que de défendre 60 ou 80
amendements
identiques de les défendre tous les uns
après les autres mais quelle idée cela
donne aux Français qui sont très
soucieux de cette question des retraites
il y a un véritable problème alors
je ne sais pas ce que vous cherchez
enfin je le devine c'est finalement de
faire en sorte que nous n'avions pas à
la fin du débat et au vote de cette loi
peut-être mais de mon point de vue je
vous le dis très tranquillement mais
tout cela ne réhausse pas l'idée que les
Français peuvent se faire du Sénat alors
j'espère j'espère que vous allez vous
ressaisir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]